emmanuel macron l'avait annoncé en 2017
d'ici 2022 terminées les centrales à
charbon en france parmi elles la
centrale emile huchet situé sur les
communes de saint-avold et de carling en
moselle elle thème ces chaudières après
71 ans d'existence la nouvelle centrale
minière de carling
produira chaque année plus de 2
milliards de kilowattheures cette
nouvelle victoire de la technique
pointer contribuera pour la plus large
part au relèvement de l'économie
nationale
depuis 1951 la centrale produisait de
l'électricité grâce au charbon à
l'époque c'était l'une des plus
importantes centrales thermiques du
bassin houiller lorrain des ouvriers de
toutes nationalités venez y travailler
est ce que vous êtes originaire vichy
alger donaldson et la gégène deutsch le
jeune allemand est chez dernière pagnol
partout autour des logements sont
construits pour les ouvriers et leurs
familles
mais à partir des années 80 extraire du
charbon en france devient plus difficile
et en importer de l'étranger et moins
cher
mauvaise période pour le secteur du
charbon mais ça n'impacte pas la
centrale de saint-avold
1981 elle s'agrandit même un peu plus
avec l'ouverture d'une nouvelle tranche
c'est qu'elle a été prévu pour
consommer exclusivement des produits
secondaires c'est à dire des résidus de
lavage des charbons et c'est pas fini
dans les années 2000 même si le charbon
n'ai plus l'énergie de demain la
centrale s'agrandit encore elle prend un
nouveau virage moins polluant que le
charbon l'électricité n'est plus
seulement produite à partir de charbon
mais aussi à partir de gaz en production
d'énergie par le gaz produit produit
beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins de polluants par
poussière pas de soufre très peu de
l'occident la zone de nouvelles tranches
au gaz sont construites en 2010 sept ans
plus tard en 2017 le président emmanuel
macron annonce vouloir fermer les
centrales à charbon en france pour des
raisons écologiques colère des salariés
de la centrale c'est très simple moi
j'ai trois enfants j'ai ma famille à
tous petits boulots à mi temps on
n'arrive à rien trouvé sa ferme ne sais
pas comment ce que derrière on n'a rien
ces faits en mars 2022 la centrale à
charbon de saint-avold cesse ses
activités elle devrait se reconvertir
dans l'hydrogène mais le gouvernement
n'exclut pas son redémarrage l'hiver
prochain en cause les déboires
rencontrés par le nucléaire et les
conséquences du conflit en ukraine
[Musique]